[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEBI CABRERA: Sorry I'm late.
Thanks for letting me in.
Good thing we're allowing
late data into our windows,
speaking of which, let's pick
up right where we left off,
dealing with windows and
late data in Apache Beam.
In the last video, we
looked at some sample data
and how Beam fits that
data into windows.
With our example data, we set
up five-second fixed windows
and talked about how
some events might not
make it into the window if the
watermark has already passed.
Data is considered late if it
comes in after Beam has already
processed the window.
So what exactly does
that mean for your data?
The default behavior is to drop
late data, which means it's not
used in any data processing.
Sometimes this might be
what you want, depending
on your business logic.
However, if you
want your pipeline
to process data that arrives
after the watermark passes
the end of the window, you
can apply an allowed lateness
when you set up your windows.
This option gives your
windows the chance
to react to late data.
If allowed lateness is
set, the default trigger
will process the new data
and send out the results
immediately.
So if we set the allowed
lateness to 10 seconds,
the final event from
our example will still
be processed because it's
less than 10 seconds late.
The result of this
late processing
will be sent to the next
step in the pipeline.
Beam uses watermarks
to provide an estimate
for knowing when no more data
is expected for a window.
And allowed lateness
gives you the ability
to allow late data
into the windows.
When we look at our example
data and the windows
after giving 10 seconds
for allowed lateness, well,
that's not quite what we
were expecting, is it?
It looks like there's two
windows with the same start
and end.
That's because they're
actually the same window
but two different
window panes, which
is what we call it when a single
window aggregation is output
as two separate elements
for downstream processing.
Depending on how you
want to handle data,
elements in a window might need
to be processed several times.
The actual results from
processing a window
are called window panes.
And they fall into
three categories--
early, on time, and late.
Up until now, we've been dealing
with on-time panes, which
are the unique output that
contains all the received
data when Beam considers
the window complete
based on the watermark.
But this new window
pane is actually late
because it has some
additional data that's
been allowed into the window,
thanks to allowed lateness.
When a window has
multiple outputs,
Beam can handle passing on
the results in two ways.
These two window panes,
one on time and one late,
have the same window properties,
like start and end time,
but not the same data.
This happens when
the data is discarded
and Beam passes
along the new process
data as a separate window pane.
If we don't want the
data to be discarded,
we can set the windows
to accumulate data
rather than discard it.
Allowing accumulating
data gives us
this, where the
late window pane now
includes all of the data
from the first pane as well.
Instead of just passing
along the new data,
beam will pass along
the entire aggregation
as a replacement for the
previous window pane.
Ultimately, it's
your business logic
that will dictate which of these
is right for your pipeline.
If you want to include late
data, deal with late data
differently, or
discard it entirely,
that's all possible through how
you set up the windows in Beam.
With our example, the first
window having two panes
means each of those
panes would be sent down
the pipeline for whatever other
processing you have set up.
One benefit to
these multiple panes
is that you can
actually process results
before the late data comes in
and then process them again
with the late data.
We've mentioned a few times
what Beam does by default,
such as the after
watermark trigger.
But one of the properties
of the Beam model
which makes it so
powerful is how you can
configure all of the behaviors.
Beam uses these
triggers to determine
when to send off the data from
a window through a window pane.
And there's lots of options
for how to configure them.
Again, the watermark
is Beam's indicator
that there is no more
expected data for that window.
The trigger for a window
is the actual mechanism
that sends off a window pane.
After watermark is the default
trigger that's actually
responsible for
this, which will only
happen once per window after
the watermark has been cleared.
That trigger will
happen no sooner
than the watermark, which
will then send off the window
pane for further processing.
Depending on if you're
allowing late data,
events after the watermark
might go into the same window
and eventually become
a late window pane.
But after watermark isn't
the only trigger you can use.
Instead of our
small example data,
what if we were
collecting millions
of events over a large
window, like 24 hours?
Having the final
data be processed
after waiting the full 24 hours
is important for completeness.
But that might increase how
long it takes to make decisions
based on that data.
Thankfully, you can use
data-driven triggers
and processing time triggers
to get early results.
Data-driven triggers
can take action
based on things like the
count of events in the window.
So even if the
window is 24 hours,
you could trigger an early
window pane after the first 20
events are processed.
In the same way, you can
use a processing time
trigger to get an early window
pane based on the processing
time.
So if you want to see some early
results after only 12 hours
of processing, you can
use a processing time
trigger to get an early pane.
But that's not all.
Triggers can be
composed together
for more flexibility on
when you want a window pane.
By using AfterAny, you can
group triggers together
so only one of the
subtriggers needs
to be met in order to tell Beam
that the window pane is ready.
Another common case
is to use repeatedly
to have the trigger continue
to process the window
as new data arrives.
If we take a look at
this code, this trigger
will happen every
time 20 events are
processed or after two hours.
It's important to note
that these triggers can
be customized, but they only
set the minimum requirements
for sending out a window pane.
Especially since Beam is
built to do distributed
data processing, there
might be a bit of extra time
or a few more events
than the minimum.
Keep that in mind as you
experiment with triggers
and customize to fit your needs.
So far, everything
we've talked about
is based on fixed windows that
have a start time and end time
and don't overlap.
Even if you don't
declare a window,
Beam still uses
the global window,
which is great for batch
jobs but not so useful
when dealing with
unbounded data.
If you want to use
windows that overlap,
you can use sliding windows.
A good way to describe
sliding windows
is to think about
doing a moving average.
If you wanted to get an
average of the number of events
in a 10-minute period
but wanted that average
to update every minute, sliding
windows would be a good fit.
Since these windows
overlap, any events
in that overlapping
time period will
be processed in both windows.
It's a good idea to understand
how intensive the event
processing is and
potentially perform
any processing before windowing
to avoid heavy resource usage.
There's one more kind of
window, session windows.
These windows are
a bit different.
Instead of start and stop
times, you specify a gap time.
This gap time is
how long a window
should wait without seeing
any activity before closing.
Using the same example of
mobile device data from before,
we might use a session window
with a gap time of five minutes
to automatically
create windows based
on when the user is active.
If the user doesn't have
any events for five minutes,
the window will close
and continue processing.
So, to recap, windows
subdivide data.
And Beam uses
triggers to send off
window panes, which could
be early, on time, or late.
Allowed lateness can be used to
allow late data into a window
past the watermark.
Windows can be fixed,
sliding, or session.
And all of these
give you the ability
to really customize your
processing pipeline.
Of course, this is a
lot of information,
and we are just
scratching the surface.
There's a link in
the description
below to a detailed
notebook where
you can try out the code for
yourself and get hands-on.
I definitely recommend
you check it out
if you want to learn more.
Thanks for watching.